je suis bénévole au secours catholique
depuis six ans et j'ai pris en trois ans
la responsabilité de l'épicerie
solidaire qui se dénomme un versailles
le groupement alimentaire familial
une épouse était déjà bénévole au
secours catholique
et c'est un ami qui m'a sollicité ton
était à la fois dans le concret dans la
gestion donc jamais quelques antécédents
professionnels dans le domaine de la
gestion notamment et je trouvais
intéressant d'allier à la fois le
bénévolat au profit des personnes dans
la difficulté et puis mes compétences
dans le domaine de la gestion d'une pme
parce que finalement l'épicerie
solidaire qui regroupe 50 de bénévoles
est une petite pme
la distribution de nourriture serré
c'est un peu une entrée en matière c'est
en 2d et ça fait partie de l'action
menée par le secours catholique qui est
de pas se contenter de distribuer mais
également d'accompagner les gens c'est à
dire de les comprendre et puis de de
cheminer avec eux de les aider alors où
on peut le faire nous même dans certains
cas ou bien on se contente de détecter
telle ou telle difficulté ou tel de tels
problèmes et de les orienter vers des
associations ou tel service ou tel
organisme qui peut les aider
le fait que ce soit le secours
catholique r est ce que ça change
quelque chose de sa change quelque chose
dans le regard qu'on a sur les gens
parce que les gens qui viennent ici
qu'on accueille ce sont des frères
ça je crois que c'est quand même assez
caractéristique de la
du catholique en fait quand on vient au
secours catholique c'est quand même dans
un certain état d'esprit avec une
certaine conviction avec une avec une
certaine foi aussi dans l'homme
n'a pas que des catholiques dans les
bénévoles mais les gens respectent ce
label catholique et quand on a des
réunions il ya toujours un moment de
prière il ya toujours enfin c'est quand
même notre caractéristique
c'est le genre de personnage que l'on
trouve à 100% de son temps
ça repose sur lui et ce soit pour les
petites oeuvres bien concrètes comme la
supervision la compta et tout ce qui est
les tâches de fond a notamment tout la
fois chapeau un travail plus que quand y
travailler
il faut faire de son mieux quoi il c'est
une mission que nous confie
je suis missionné par le secours
catholique pour faire fonctionner cette
épicerie solidaire
en accord avec le secours catholique
donc
si j'ai pris cet engagement je vais le
faire au mieux de mes capacités ça ne
veut pas dire je le fais toujours très
bien mais je fais j'essaie de faire en
sorte que que cette mission bien je la
remplis ce jeu-là remplissent à la
satisfaction notamment des personnes que
nous accueillons parce qu'en fait c'est
bon c'est pour elle qu'on est là oui est
ce que j'essaie aussi c2a c'est de créer
une bonne ambiance
à l'intérieur de cette maison fait entre
les bénévoles eux-mêmes avec les
accueillir il est arrivé par une gestion
vraiment rigoureuses à ce que ce soit
complètement l équilibre
dysfonctionnements ou tard beaucoup de
chance de l'avoir
il régule énormément tout posé
tous nos petits défauts ne peut arriver
qu'avec les bénévoles on est quelques
soucis au niveau notamment de ces sas
produit souvent au niveau des quantités
à distribuer bien entendu on ad on a des
règles de distribution va pas distribuer
des produits de manière inconsidérée
donc tel type de produit on peut
redonner un par semaine ou un tous les
15 jours selon les compositions des
familles bon alors il ya des gens qui
comprennent pas très bien ça parce que
c'est ce que j'appelle un peu le
bénévole au grand coeur qui qui
donnerait tout or c'est pas respecter
les gens que lui ont redonné plus qu'ils
n'ont besoin et puis il ya également un
problème d'équité entre les personnes
qui sont autour de la table qui sont
accueillis il faut que tout le monde
soit traité de la même façon
c'est pas monsieur untel qui donne c'est
le secours catholique qui donne c'est
pas nous même c'est pas on doit pas se
mettre en avant donc on n'a pas à
essayer de plaire aux gens et donc c'est
pour ça que là dessus je suis assez
strict je sais que parfois je suis pas
toujours très bien compris mais après on
vient de dire oui finalement tu as
il ya un double sens en fait dans cet
engagement y est ce que moi je peux
apporter mais il ya aussi ceux que je
reçois à la fois des bénévoles qui
m'entourent parce qu'on est on est une
équipe
et chacun apporte sa part et qu'on
reçoit forcément et puis aussi ce qu'on
reçoit des gens qu'on accueille et il ya
aussi une expérience qui est très
intéressant que c'est celle des
collectes où on est en contact avec tous
les gens qui viennent acheter et où
on voit que ce sont pas toujours ceux
qui sont les plus aisés qui donnent le
plus et j'ai encore l'expérience de la
dernière collecte nous avons réalisé aux
chaînés où une dame nous apporte et deux
paquets de pâtes en disant je peux pas
vous donner plus je suis au chômage et
chiant longue maladie mais je veux
vraiment participer mais aussi et là
c'est vraiment touchant quand on a des
témoignages comme ça c'est quand même
extraordinaire